reddit is the ultimate source of
information you choose what kind of
content you care about and the world
votes on what pieces of information are
noteworthy because reddit is so
democratic bad content is filtered out
and you see only the best a person's
authority and integrity is decided by
their karma a measure of the success of
their posts someone with many lousy
posts will receive lots of down votes
giving them a negative karma and telling
users to be wary of their posts in the
future there is a bit of a problem
though people vote based on their
agreement with content instead of its
quality so because you want your post
seen and don't want your comic to drop
your pressured into posting not what you
think but what the community wants once
an idea has just barely a majority of
support it can dominate reddit thinking
by becoming the most popular opinion an
idea becomes what the community wants
and the cycle continues post will be
catered to that idea out of social
pressure and all dissenting opinions
will be silenced if opinion a has 40
percent support opinion be 31% and see
twenty nine opinion a will become
popular opinion and swallow almost all
discussion on the topic opinion a may
receive 90% of posts and up votes
because of its lead however small but
bystanders will reasonably assume it
means 90% of the community supports
opinion a you can expect a plethora of
different political opinions from the
three million people and 11,000 separate
communities within Reddit but this
spread isn't apparent out of the popular
political posts in 2015 almost all
support a single candidate given
reddit's leanings it does make sense
that the most liberal candidate has a
disproportionate amount of support but
the fact that there is almost no other
opinion posted suggests not that it
doesn't exist but that people are afraid
to post against the majority a study on
reddit social influence found that the
first votes on a post largely decide its
level of success posts were randomly
voted up or down and it was found that
this single vote had a huge influence on
other voters because of this often will
has become the majority opinion is
entirely arbitrary decided by who votes
first it's possible that what seems to
be the majority opinion is actually a
minority but everyone is simply
following the
assuming everyone else is being sincere
but reddit gets you going and coming
what you think is not what you post so
your actions are filtered and what you
see posted which has already been
filtered affects what you think reddit
is designed to be a marketplace of ideas
a place of disagreement and acceptance
and even though karma is immensely
useful for creating accountability it
often stifles diversity by punishing it
[Music]